so not very long ago rodriguez from the
american conservative
as well as a few other media outlets uh
published
a comment on an article on a scholarly
article
that talked about creating a human
monkey hybrid in an embryo form
and they talk about how they did it you
know the the case
and they even use the word uh chimera
which is the ancient word they used to
talk about these
mythical monsters that were mixture
between different types
of beings and i want to look at this
together with you
not for the shock value not just because
it's strange and it's odd but because
the symbolism that i talk about there's
something objective about it and when i
talk about
being attentive to the signs the signs
of the end of
something the signs of the end of uh
story
these are objective and they will
manifest themselves
there are different ways that that can
happen but they will happen symbolism
really does happen and this is
particularly a case a sign of the times
to help us see where we are in the story
this is jonathan pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
so in the ancient world in the story
of noah and the flood and the traditions
surrounding that especially
there is this idea that before the flood
or before the end of a world
there was a moment where there were
hybrids where there is a mixture between
the sons of god
and the daughters of men now there are
different interpretations of this
there are interpretations we talk about
the lineage of cain mixing which
with the lineage of seth and there are
also interpretations that talk about how
it is that uh
angels fallen angels would have
relationships with humans but for our
particular understanding it doesn't
matter that much which
interpretation you follow if you even
follow both interpretations
it's mostly important to understand that
one of the aspects of the end of a world
is hybridity and this is not a just
something that
you describe but it isn't the very
meaning
of what it means for something to reach
its end
i've talked about this many times before
but here we really have an example
of a sign of the time that is helping us
understand
where we are and how the possibilities
of a world
will actually manifest the shape of
reality
so the shape of reality is the notion of
identity
is based on the idea that there is a
something which is one whether it's a
person whether
it's a nation whether it's a community
whatever it is
there's a manner in which we are capable
of seeing the unity
and this unity has a coherence there's
something which binds us together
something in common we have something in
common which binds us together
and as you move away from the most
common or the
elements that are their most most uh
have the most in common
it lays itself out as a hierarchy and as
you move away from that
you reach certain idiosyncrasies and
then ultimately
you reach the buffer between that
identity and other identities
and that buffer is a place of hybrids
now this can be true almost of any
category
and so you you can sometimes they don't
necessarily manifest
but you can imagine for example uh you
know you
the the modern world has actually been
extremely good at trying to create these
hybrid type of uh even hybrid objects
where
you know it's a it's a flashlight
and a pen at the same time it's
different things at the same time
it's the it's two different identities
that we can recognize that are kind of
jammed into
one identity and this is this is what
happens in the buffer of the world and
it
laid itself out in the ancient
cosmologies where on
in the middle you would have you know
some
some uh founder some god
some central figure that is the the one
that we all looked toward to that
brought down the law for example in the
case of moses
you know that brought kingship that
brought unity somehow
and then as you move away from that
person
you come to the edge where it's the
place where
you're in a border with what is foreign
to you
and so imagine different countries
different empires and on the border
between different countries then you
will necessarily
have hybridity you'll have a mixture
right if you live on the border between
two countries
there you'll have people that intermarry
between the the two identities it's just
going to
happen naturally and there's a there's a
a function for that it acts as a as a
buffer zone
you know to to to create a little bit of
space between two identities
where um you know where it isn't just a
complete
uh shutting off or complete cutting off
it's like a breathing space
where you can actually get potential
from the other identity
uh and so there's a there's a kind of
there's a certain openness on the board
but it's on the border right it's not
happening in the center
when i say that a lot of people will all
the sudden be suspicious because they're
noticing
how the narrative of hybridity is taking
over the world right we value hybridity
we
value the idea of mixture in so many
domains
whether it is in terms of culture the
idea that
we want to have all these different
restaurants and different kinds of foods
with different kinds of identities
all of this is something that we value
usually that reality
is like i said on the border but now we
are we're pretty much embodying it in
all of our culture
and just like in the time of the flood
this
was necessarily going to move into
extremes
uh we've already seen a form of chimera
in the past you know the idea that
they're injecting genes of animals into
um to fruits or vegetables the idea that
they're using different genes from
certain animals like everybody probably
saw the glow in the dark pigs that they
created
by uh by using certain genes from
phosphorus animals
and then putting in them into the pigs
so we're already seeing
little versions of chimera
you've probably seen these weird images
of people growing
uh like let's say ears on rats and like
all this kind of strange stuff that is
happening
and so it was inevitable that it would
come
to the actual creation of a chimera just
like
as the world lays itself out on the edge
of the world there are monsters there
are things that don't fit into
categories
as we value the the monstrous
the exception the hybridity it was
necessarily going to happen
as what i say like a sign of the times
that we would actually go towards uh
hybridity itself in terms of
human animal librarity um you can see it
almost as a
like as a layer lower like you can
imagine like the first cycle before the
flood
as being kind of higher we have the the
higher beings mixing with
the lower beings and then once again you
have higher beings mixing with lower
beings but at a lower level where
instead of
um instead of having um gods mixing with
human or
angels mixing with humans like you see
in the great greek myth for example
now you have the lower being which is
more the the minotaur
version of hybridity which is the
the uh you know the woman mixing with
the bull
in the the myth and then you see that
right now with the idea of creating the
hybrids
and so this problem of creating hybrids
and creating monsters
is of course
it is very much the problem of of a
labyrinth it is the problem where
identity starts to fracture and it
starts to break down
and it brings about a lot of chaos but
it's also going to bring about
other strange things as well and people
are already talking about how
the danger of doing that is to it's like
you're
you're creating a lower form of being
that will somehow be akin to you but not
completely so you can imagine like the
creation of orcs or these monsters out
of the ground
this is what is is actually happening
and so people will
will say well it's just it's just an
embryo it's just a fetus
it's not a complete person first of all
the fact that they're telling this
publicly means that they've done a lot
of other things in private before
letting this out publicly so there might
be things out there
that we're not that we're not aware
aware of because if they're willing to
show this to us in public
then there are other things going on as
well and the narrative
will play itself out this is one of the
things that i
try to to bring up is that once you
start a certain series of events
once you engage in a story then that
story
is going to play itself out the
characters might change
the people who embody the characters
might change and so yes this scientist
that did
that maybe made the the monkey human
embryo
will not be necessarily be the one to go
all the way
and bring this being into the world in
in terms of
you know being born then it doesn't
matter because you've opened up
a space and then someone else is going
to go into that space
and then when you open up that space
then someone else is going to go into
the other space
these things just will once you create
a possibility someone will come and
inhabit that possibility
and uh and so i just wanted to to help
you see that when i talk about
the shape of the world and this idea
that you know
on the edge of the world are these
monsters and are these exceptions and
all this weird stuff
and when i told you that we're going to
see things that we haven't seen in
thousands of years
this is already something that is on the
horizon and that
is appearing that is the uh
the the old mythological image of a
chimera
right the one that all the rationalists
thought were just their imagination
were just this stupid thing that they
imagined that there were these beings
that
were a mixture of different uh
identities and different you know
centaurs and ciders
and all of these human hybrid characters
they're they're there we actually
manifest they might not look
the way that they're represented in
mythological uh storytelling
but they're going to exist in the world
because that's where we are
and symbolism happens so i just wanted
to put that out a little bit
i didn't want to insist on it too much
but i just wanted to
to point people to the fact that this is
a serious
thing this question of of how symbolic
structures happen
and lay themselves out they're not just
allegorical
they really do get embodied in the world
so we have to be careful
we have to be careful of the things that
we put out in the world we're not in
control of what's being put out in the
world
sadly but it can also help you see that
if we put out
real stories into the world if we put
out the
the versions of the real story into the
world then that will
also create a possibility that will be
inhabited
and so as this entire world is going
towards the uh
you know the fallen angel ai
and hybrid hybrid human animal
thing realize that this is a sign of the
times not
arbitrary at all but completely coherent
with the way the world actually lays
itself out and for those who are
attentive
we can understand what is happening and
hopefully try to be
try to be an antidote through telling
better stories
being part of better stories
participating in
in the real world and so thank you for
your attention everybody thank you for
your support
with everything that's been going on um
i in the last
few weeks after the jordan peterson
discussion a lot
i've been putting out less videos i was
kind of overwhelmed by a wave
of all kinds of questions and attentions
and interviews some of them you might
not have seen but
requests for writing articles and
requests for all this stuff
and so i'm just kind of surfing this
wave but i've got a lot of videos uh
coming
very soon i ended up recording the
the whole kind of weird satanic little
nasa video
and i've got several discussions on the
line as well
including with uh voter laskan who wrote
the
novel loris that i'm extremely excited
to have a chance to uh
interview him because he also has this
intuition
that we're at a transition mode and
we're entering a
or we're closer to a world that will be
re-enchanted once again so thanks again
i'll talk to you soon